Black Friday is likely to set records
today the day after Thanksgiving with
millions of shoppers getting up before
dawn to start spending others lined up
at stores around the country looking for
the best Black Friday deals more than
164 million Americans are expected to
shop during the five-day stretch from
Thanksgiving to Cyber Monday
analysts expect this weekend sales to be
up 17 percent from last year in total
this year's holiday sales could top one
trillion dollars Omar Villafranca is in
Frisco Texas north of Dallas inside a
store that has been open since 2:00 p.m.
yesterday
Omar good morning good morning this
JCPenney will actually stay open until
10:00 p.m. tonight that's 32 hours
straight that they will be open and
managers say one of the big sellers will
always be apparel including stuff for
the little kids now we ran into people
who were the first time black friday
shopper but there's also some people who
skip turkey dinner altogether to be part
of this bargain hunting tradition
millions of shoppers across the country
of rushing into stores on the hunt for
big bargains this holiday season 17 inch
TV for 600 bucks
there was lines outside we're spending
all the money that we need during the
year some shoppers skipped out on the
turkey and others in the Northeast
braved record cold temperatures in long
lines for a good deal I have friends and
family back at home sitting around like
a fire and like warm food
chaos filled some stores as people
frantically grabbed items from the
shelves more than 164 million people are
expected to shop in-store and online
this weekend sales are expected to reach
at least 17 billion dollars through
Monday this is a year where people just
seem ready to shop at all income
brackets sera nos our from The Wall
Street Journal says retailers overall
are in a much better place this year if
a retailer can't do well this holiday
season that's a bad sign the economy is
good low income wages are rising that
means they weren't doing something right
because the consumers are shopping right
now look at work California mom Jennifer
gamble says she started shopping on
Black Friday 20 years ago
her family started planning on Wednesday
evening they spend Thanksgiving night
shopping for holiday gifts and items
they're donating to a family in need the
gambles plan on doing some shopping
today but also continuing their shopping
tomorrow now if you're wondering if you
got a good deal in store experts say
it's a good idea to look at things
online before you go shopping black Omar
thank you very much I do exactly just
that